Speaker 1: When a Democratic president is in
power very often, Fox News talks about the war
on Christmas a lot, and we now have a pandemic
which has affected holidays for some time.
And Fox News is going absolutely crazy over very
milquetoast comments that Anthony Fauci made.
I'm going to play the clip for you that started
it all. Dr. Fauci was asked over the weekend.
Our Christmas gatherings, good to
go. And he responding to a question,
said it's just too early to say,
Speaker 4: but we can gather for Christmas
or it's just too soon to tell.
Speaker 5:
You know, Margaret, it's just too soon to tell.
We've just got to concentrating on continuing
to get those numbers down and not trying
to jump ahead by weeks or months and say
what we're going to do at a particular time.
Speaker 1: Fauci didn't cancel Christmas.
He didn't even come out and say, I must talk about
Christmas. He was asked the question and he said,
it's just kind of early. Fox News has
now been going for 48 hours with the idea
that Fauci is canceling Christmas. Look at these
clips. Here is Jason Rantz, who is a radio host
in Seattle. Listen to this unhinged insanity.
Speaker 5: Seventy five percent or so to tell
me that it's not safe to visit your family
for Christmas. To see that now in October
indicates this isn't really about
public health at this point.
Now we're talking about taking total control.
Speaker 1: Now, understand what he did there,
this guy saying. In October,
Fauci saying No Christmas,
no in October found she's saying Christmas
is too far away to talk about Christmas. We
just need to see what's happening with the virus.
Another example here is, I think this is Kennedy
saying, why is she talking about
Christmas? Well, he was asked about it.
He didn't come up with the question.
Speaker 3: Problem is, he's talking
about Christmas and Hanukkah. We haven't
gotten to Halloween and Thanksgiving Columbus
Day. Thank you, Dana. We're getting rid of that.
Kids did not get to have a Halloween last year,
right? And it's like, you know, you have
little kids, you only have so many of them.
My daughter last year had to bake a twilight cake
Speaker 1: with a gravestone. OK, yeah.
Making drama where there is no drama.
Why is she talking about Christmas?
Because he was asked by Margaret Brennan about
Christmas. That's why then the histrionics
really get going with Tucker Carlson. Tucker,
it's incredible what Tucker is able to do with
this. The histrionic nature of this. Take a look.
Speaker 5: There was do not travel for Christmas,
Anthony Fauci said. Do not congregate together
to celebrate it. That means no Christmas Eve in
church. That means no Christmas morning under the
Speaker 1: tree with you. It's
an attack on religion like
Speaker 5: tearing through stockings.
It means no Christmas stockings. Sacred Christian
observance canceled until further notice from Dr.
Anthony Fauci, M.D.. What a thrill it must
have been for him to say something like that.
Oh yeah. Here's a guy who fully expected to spend
his life giving prostate exams. And there he was,
declaring the ancient Christian calendar null and
Speaker 1: void, by the way, is what it was.
Was Foushee heading towards urology as a spouse? I
don't even know what the prostate exam thing even
is, so tucker blowing it completely out of the
water. Here's another right wing guy, Clay Travis,
saying Fauci's just trying to control holidays.
Speaker 5: Everyone, but I have to say
it, Foushee There the constitution matters
the most in times of emergency and crisis
because that's when the foundation of our
country's documents matter the absolute.
Speaker 1: Imagine Dr. Fauci, what do you think
about Christmas? I don't know. It's too soon
to tell. This guy is attacking the Constitution
Speaker 5: and the idea that he's trying to argue
to us that we can't celebrate Christmas together.
And now he's saying, Oh, I didn't say that,
but you did say it. He didn't say it.
Speaker 1: He didn't say it. He said
it's just too soon to tell. And then
lastly, here is one more of these,
and it's just more pathetic than the last. Yes.
Speaker 3: After calling for the cancelation
of Christmas again, somehow
Anthony Fauci still has his job.
Speaker 1: Never happened. Just never happened.
And this is how the narratives start and continue.
This one has the same texture as the Dr. Seuss,
who, by the way, is not a medical doctor. Folks,
you should know about that. These people are
pathetic, but they don't have anything else.
So this is what they're doing. Remember that
on Tuesday, October 19th, we will be doing a
live viewer townhall. It will be streaming live
exclusively only on the Pacman Live YouTube
channel, which you can find at YouTube.com slash
Pacman Live. It won't be streaming on Facebook.
It won't be streaming on Tik Tok. It won't be on
the main YouTube channel. It won't be on Twitch.
The Pacman Live Channel six p.m.
Eastern on Tuesday, October 19th.
Everybody can call in members on our website. Get
Priority will be a great event, and I hope to see
all of you. Then let's take a quick break and
we have quite a program planned for you today.